so so this film initially was a short
right and can add that can you take us
back to how that first the idea of it
even has a short first came to you and
and we're all of you involved as far
back is that or was it the feature that
brought you together sure yeah we had my
Uncle Frank I always told this story at
family gatherings about he and my other
two uncles setting fire to my
grandfather's Jeep when they were little
and sort of the aftermath of when my
grandfather came home to all this mass
destruction and it was just always a fun
little tale that he would tell and I
wrote a little like six seven page
script kind of based off of that and I
hadn't made anything I'd been writing a
lot and hadn't made anything in a while
and I teach at the University of Texas
in Austin my kids are on set like every
weekend making something I'm like why am
I not doing that so I pulled the script
out and i called up kelly who was just
leaving the austin film festival and was
like hey I have this project do you want
to go hang out on the playground this
summer and make something with our
friends so we had no expectations
whatsoever we were just really just
wanted to get back out and play and make
something and then after like a three
days shoot summer of 2011 I just loved
these characters this father struggling
with these hell raising boys and wanted
to live with them longer and see kind of
what brought them to such dysfunction to
this place and someone on sets that I
think that this world lives in Port
Arthur Texas Southeast Texas Beaumont
area and then Kelly piped in with oh I'm
from there so he started like literally
like a week or two after we wrapped the
short took me down to visit that area
and it's you know it's so stunningly
cinematic I mean you see refineries
everywhere and at night it's just all
lit up like like oz it's really just
striking I hadn't seen it on screen
outside of maybe like urban cowboy and I
just fell in love with the place and I
just started literally sitting in
barbershops listening to a refinery
worker
coming in and out sitting at Larry's
French market having the buffet with you
know the all that everyone that lives
there eating alligator for the first
time and just sort of kind of soaking up
the world and the people and location
really inspired the movie the short
played in 2012 and Kelly and I had a
film at sundance and 13 and he had gone
through the sundance producing lab so
literally we were in park city and
thinking that we really wanted to have
Hellion there the next year you know if
we could we could make it happen so you
know we just knew that we had come out
to grab each other and move forward and
to do that you know we had to find the
resources and that was a challenge it
was a I don't think we want it say the
film no job probably not but you know I
mean what it was it was super low but
breaking her yeah I were working around
I was shot in 26 days so he was like you
know so fast with particularly having
miners every day of the set you know
every day that was Josh I think had one
day off the whole shoot and is there
something they can only work a certain
number of hours there right yeah there
is that but I mean it was shooting the
summertime and then trying to share the
film with the deadline that Sundance
sets in order to be eligible and then
you know because we had this grant from
the San Francisco Film Society we've got
to go to Skywalker and so we were all
there together and cat left directly
from San Francisco to go directly to
Sundance with a copy of the film in her
hand yes you always hear those stories I
was like oh we actually didn't actually
like it you know handcuffed to her oh
yeah briefcase button well I get I would
obviously be remiss if we didn't talk
about the casting of this because for on
the one hand you it was must have been
pretty exciting to get people who are
really established like Aaron Pollock
julia Louis but also if you didn't find
such a towel
the kid to play the the main part you
don't have a movie no matter whoever
else is in it so can you just let us
know in what sequence the cast came
together and because I I mean I guess
one thing I wonder is whether chemistry
with our and Paul was was tested before
you cast Josh so let me yeah we um our
cast our Texas casting director worked
on the tree of life and so we kind of
took the approach that those guys took
in going into small towns with
permission and kind of sitting in
cafeterias and watching all of these
boys and getting a real kind of sense of
their personalities and then sending
home letters to parents and getting them
to come in and audition and when I say
audition it was really just kind of
sitting there and talking to them and
kind of getting to know them a little
bit and then you know improving a scene
or two and see how the stretch of their
imagination and and we also did the same
thing with motocross races we went all
across the state of Texas and went all
these races which was both beautiful
informative for the story and the script
and then yeah finding all these other
kids and we I think we started that
process like around mid-april we went
out to aaron i want to say end of april
i think we kind of had him attached by
early May but I was scouting boys for a
really long time I mean two-thirds of
the Battle of getting a great
performance from a kid is in the casting
and really being patient with seeing all
of these boys one of our kids came from
Port Neches where we shot the movie it
was a very first audition that we did
we'd seen like 100 kids Dalton satin who
plays lance and then Cameron Owens came
from the very first motocross race that
I went to and date garner the youngest
boy was in the short film he was the
lead in the short Dylan the redhead came
from just general talent agencies and
then Josh are our friends summer Shelton
who was in the producers lab with Callie
she was producing a movie called little
accidents at the same time which was at
Sundance
a great great film so they were looking
for 14 year old southern boys as well
and she was interested in a boy from our
short film started researching him
online and found all these YouTube
videos he made with his best friend Josh
Wiggins called us up and I was like
there's something really special about
this kid and I mean even though you're
watching like bad detective where
they're in the backyard and the pool and
like little cowboy hats and fake guns
there was something really flawless and
easy about him in front of the camera
and very natural and what I brought him
in it was just like you know the heavens
opened up and you've seen like all these
kids and this kid is just so like
strikingly authentic so he went through
several rounds of auditions but in that
moment when he walked in the room it was
just like you kinda knew in your gut
like this is my kid and then I brought
him out later kind of in the process to
meet with Aaron and then it was like
doubly sure like when you got that when
I got them in the room it was I remember
just like turning around to my casting
director would like this huge smile on
my face being like this this is my
family and there's something really
magical going on here